Hey Youtubers agents of shield coming back next
week there's a whole bunch of stuff is going
on the changes going on with Doctor strange
in the movies.
So let's break it down there is a new Hulkbuster
giveaway that starting now.
For agents of shield videos.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything, but it
seems like she just got real she's turning
into Ultron really what's going on here.
So let's do top 10, number 10 they are passing
the torch from ghost rider to life model decoys
for like the story arc the back half of the
season if you're behind the last couple of
episodes have slowly been ramping up Ada's
plot like she slowly becoming a bigger and
bigger thing remember at the beginning of
the season.
They just tease her like oh my God there's
a life model decoys and she's hilariously
inappropriate she just says really awkward
things and it's funny.
So number nine the dark hold plot became a
big thing with the Ghost Rider character this
mystery book that was a bit of makeup and
it was really dangerous people read from it.
Went crazy the human mind couldn't handle
it.
So number eight they had Aida read it because
her computer brain which is capable of processing
so much more information.
So the joke about this is when they were realizing
that human mind couldn't handle the dark hold
agent may is the one who insisted Ada read
it.
So they can find a way to defeat.
Eli Morrow.
Doctor Radcliffe shaking his head no no no.
So number seven the big reveal is that may
is a life model decoys she totally could have
read the book herself, but even though Ada
seems like she's gained this crazy power from
reading the dark cold you know number seven
she actually seems like she swapped in life.
Model decoys may a long time ago.
So if you remember way back to episode four.
That was the last time we can confirm we saw
human may being treated by, Ada, because at
the end of the last episode.
They did the big reveal where she was keeping
me locked up in that little life model decoys
closet in the fake mate was with Coulson saying
I'm right where I need to be like, it's meant
to be this really touching moment but you
the scary music in the background like oh
my God was their plan, is this going to be
like a bunch of silent style old Tron replicants
whatever this has to do with the dark cold
it was all set in motion before Ada read the
dark hold.
So she'd been planning this this whole time.
So number six the dark old brain.
We don't actually know if Ada has installed
that yet but basically what it seems like
it is.
Is it something to free herself from outside
control like.
If you've ever heard of the idea of an airgap
computer.
It's a computer that's never been connected
to the Internet.
So it's like a self-contained system.
It seems like that was the reason the Ada
build that special brain for herself, but
it might also do some really special stuff
to because it's basically made of dark matter
like she built the gateway that allowed Coulson
and Fitz to come back from the dark dimension
they been really careful about what they call
that other place to is basically hell is Ghost
Rider explains it like the spirit of vengeance
inside Ghost Rider tells them.
I am not going back there were, but is whatever
the gonna call it, it really is marbles version
of health.
So we're getting into prime Mephisto stuff
the kinda bleeds into Doctor strange door
Mahmoud dark dimension stuff to because number
five creating something from nothing that
was Eli Morrow's big thing like look I can
create matter out of nothing and Fitz in like
pretty much every other scientist on the TV
show is like that's bull shit you can't create
something out of nothing.
That energy has to come from somewhere.
So if you remember the zealots from Doctor
strange they drew energy from other dimensions
to power their spells and when they drew from
the dark dimension.
It was like extra powerful energy, so number
for the follow-up question what about Ghost
Rider in Eli Morrow at the end of the season
like blaze of glory style Ghost Rider goes
out like a champ and is basically trying to
take Eli Morrow back to hell, take him back
to this other dimension where all this mystery
energy is coming from.
So technically it is another dimension, but
we can just call it hell for all intents and
purposes, just because that's with the spirit
of vengeance inside Ghost Rider was calling
it.
So when they say that the show is moving its
focus to life model decoys.
It doesn't mean that Ghost Rider's never coming
back that just means that he's trapped in
hell right now he will definitely come back
by the end of the season it's some big moment,
but the question is is will we actually get
to see what's going on in hell because you're
going over to like the Thor comics there was
appeared of time the Thor was trapped in the
as guardian version of hell HEL hell at the
mercy of Hella but as you can imagine being
at the mercy of the devil is just like endless
torture both psychological and physical killing
you every day then bringing you back to life.
So that she can torture you and kill you again
over and over and over.
They actually did that on Westworld.
I've died millions of times.
I'm great at it so that just seems like there's
a lot of like AI stuff going on a pop-culture
right now you have AI robots gone crazy on
Westworld I you have AI robots on agents of
shield gone crazy, but number three don't
forget the other big storyline is the new
mystery Inhumans the Jeffrey Mays the patriot
was making this deal behind the scenes to
try and take care of what we know is that
the government official that is been blackmailing
Jeffrey Mays knows who this person is, and
it seems like a fairly high ranking or a wealthy
person.
A person of importance that they're trying
to hide the identity of and even though they
kind of dropped the Inhumans storyline on
agents of shield the big runner was rights
for Inhumans like we deserve all of the same
treatment as regular people, so the like this
underclass of citizens right now in the world.
So I'm guessing that storyline is words can
loopback around and grab this new mystery
in human because Jeffrey Mays like went public
on TV and said I am an in human they put me
in charge of shield because I'm trustworthy
is big deal is trust.
Even though he's been very not trustworthy
the season so far, but just remember that
even though it doesn't seem like it's a big
deal there will be more inhuman stuff happening
later via this new mystery in human.
So number two Jeffrey Mays the patriot he's
an in human no strength on par with Captain
America as if you were to have the super soldier
serum the big wink here is that way back in
the classic Captain America comics the patriot
wielded the mantle of Captain America and
the shield for appeared of time so everyone's
asking like will you get to wield the shield.
So just know Morrow the voice of Batman the
guy who's playing Jeffrey Mays on the TV show.
I love the Batman is the director of shield
right now to get the end of Civil War Captain
America leaves the shield behind.
So nobody is wielding the shield right now
so if patriot was such a big character.
They chose him for reason on the TV show in
turn them into an in human is like a slight
change from the comics the patriot is not
an in human in the comics.
They just want him to seem like a Captain
America type character so I think that that
means that he will eventually wield Captain
America's shield whether or not it's like
the energy shield the Coulson has or the actual
physical Captain America's shield with the
number one big thing though is in actually
finding out what is the intelligence behind
this other dimension.
So everybody is wondering does that mean that
Mephisto is eventually going to come on the
TV show because he gets really confusing when
you talk about who has the TV ride to as the
movie rights for different characters.
Technically Mephisto appeared for the first
time during a silver surfer, comic that's
outfox character but that's the movies not
the TV shows Marvel actually still has the
rights for X-Men on TV which is a really weird
situation, so let me know in the comments
what you most hype about for the back half
of agents of shield life model decoys or really
finding who's controlling this other dark
dimension that the Ghost Rider spirit of vengeance
is so afraid of just reminder agents of shield
is back next week so I will do in episode
video but what can happen is is at the end
of the month when all the DC shows come back.
There's gonna be a logjam of videos because
legends of tomorrow is moving to Tuesday nights.
So I got like a whole bunch of videos that
I'll have to try and do with it like a really
small span of time.
So some of it is good have to get pushed a
little bit to like Thursdays so you guys like
this what I'm to do because of the doing the
Spider-Man giveaway is a Mexican a do a whole
combustor giveaway for agents of shield just
for the agents of shield videos.
So be sure to look out for that when I post
it next Tuesday Baldwin started now so I'll
announce the winner in that first agents of
shield video but up next tonight I guess.
New flash season 3 posting, so that should
be up a little while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn all about
the Doctor strange team up in Thor Ragnarok
and you can click here to learn about all
the crazy stuff that's coming up thank you
so much for watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tonight!